ان ابقى في تفاصيل الزفاف الملكي الاردني
بث مباشر لساعات وساعات وتغطيه خاصه تضمنت
العديد من اللحظات العفويه التي لا تنسى
وشاهدها العالم ايضا هي قراءه بين السطور
سطور العرس الملكي للحظات ومواقف لا تنسى
لكن بلغه الجسد لنتعرف اكثر عما لم تبح به
الكلمات
[موسيقى]
للغايه
لنور كل مكان
ليله الد
[موسيقى]
مام ومحبوب امير نشمي مهيوب هذا ابن هواشم
هذا امير
اتزينت عما
المحبوب امير نشمي مهيوب هذا ابن هواشف
[موسيقى]
اذا ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
عادل القراعيين اختصاصي الصحه النفسيه
بالطاقه الحيويه ومدرب حياه واعمال دكتور
خليني اشوف بانه ابرز ما لفت نظرك في هذا
العرس شدك من لغه الجسد والحركات التي
كانت معبره
اول شيء اللي شدني اللي هو عفويه وبساطه
العائله الملكيه طبعا احنا بلغه الجسد هي
بتعبر عن تراكمات للمشاعر والتصرفات
والسلوكيات حتى المهارات على مدى السنوات
فهي بتعكس لغتنا
والتصرفاتنا الطبيعيه خلينا نبلش باول
لحظه تفضل لحظه حب الاميره رجوه
وربطت العنق هذه التي نشاهدها
للامير تعديلها لربطه العنق شلون نفسرها
بلغه القصر يعني ربطه العنق بالذات اذا
بدنا نفسر هذه اللقطه نحتاج الى ساعات
طويله ولكن بالمختصر اول شيء ترتيب ربطه
العنق عم بتدل على اول شيء انها الطاقه
الانثويه يعني سمو الاميره رجوى عاليه جدا
والطاقه الانثويه تعني اللي هو احترامي
لذاتي وثقتي بنفسي والعنايه بالاخرين ما
دام احنا بنحكي هون عن
عن موضوع مؤسسه الزواج والزواج هو موده
ورحمه اللي هي بتشمل الحب العميق ايضا
فربطه العنق تدل على الموده العنايه انا
بطلع على جميع التفاصيل وانا بدي كل شيء
يكون على ما يرام
ايضا
يعني ايضا حوالي ينفض شيء
لانهم نحن سند لبعض ننتقل للنقطه اللي
بعدها وهذا ربما من ابرز اللقطات اللي
لفتتني الاميرتان ايمان وسلمى
بتعدلان ثوب العروس رجوى قمه في التواضع
اكيد هي بتدل على التواضع بتدل انه يعني
نحن العائله وانت سمو الاميره رجوه اصبحتي
اخت كبيره لنا واخت من العائله فنحن نظهر
احترامنا سندنا الك وتواضعنا وكمان في
الموضوع في لمسه انثويه يعني السيدات
والاميرات ايمان وسلمى
عندهم حس الاناقه والرقيه اللي هو الانثوي
فلهيك هم كانوا مركزين انه اطلالتها تكون
في افضل حالاتها اكيد طيب لقطه عفويه
ثانيه احنا رصدناها يعني اللي هي تصرف
ابناء ملك الاردن عند سقوط حقيبه الملكه
رانيا خلونا نشوفها
اذا هذه هي الايه سقطت الحقيبه وجميعهم
يعني حاولوا انهم يسترجعوا لها العريس
الكل فزع لها لانه قبل ما تكون ملكه وقبل
ما يكونوا امراء واميرات هم هم واولاد
فهذه هي التربيه زي ما حكيت في البدايه
انه احنا باللغه الجسد هي بتكون في شيء في
العقل اللاواعي فطرتنا الانسانيه فهذا
دليل انهاء سموه
الامير طبعا رده فعله مع جلاله الملكه كان
دليل على حسن التربيه والتنشئه وهم
تعاونوا معها كام قبل ما يتعاملوا معها
ايضا في لقطه الحقيقه بتعكس يعني تعب
الملك عبد الله بعد يوم طويل من الزفاف
ايضا
عائليه طلب الامير الحسين من الجميع
الاقتراب والرقص سويا
خلينا نشوف
وقديش قديش في الفرحه يعني واضحه ما الذي
تعنيه النوع تعالوا كلنا نرقص ونتجمع برضو
كمان تراكمات على مدى السنوات يعني احنا
بنعرف سمو الامير الحسين يعني ليس فقط
قريبا من الشعب بل هو منخرط من الشعب يعني
بتعرف بالجيش يعني
هلا مش كسر يعني انا ممكن مش الشخص
الافضل العفويه العفويه طبعا العفويه لانه
حكينا مهما كنا منمقين مهما كنا مرتبين
الا عفويه وفطرتنا تظهر من خلال لغه الجسد
فبالنهايه هو قربه من شعبه هو اللي جعله
انه انا كنت سندكم اليوم انتم سند وفرحتكم
فرحتي واخر لقطع بنشوفها
ام العسريه
كما نرى اكيد دلاله ماذا طبعا برضه بعلم
النفس وشريعا المشي البطيء يقال عنه انه
هو الافضل ولكن بعلم النفس المشي السريع
قد يكون الافضل لانه بعبر عن فطرتنا
فالمشي السريع يعني هنا والله اعلم انها
بتعبر عن حماسها بزواج ابنتها وانها شغف
وانها بدها توصل لتحقيق كل شيء انه يكون
على ما يرام وحابه تشوف بنتها في افضل
حالاتها
اكيد
الشكر اذا كان معنا طبعا دكتور عادل
القراعيين اختصاصي الصحه النفسيه بالطاقه
الحيويه ومدرب حياته واعمال لا شكرا جزيلا
دكتور عادل يعطيكم الف عافيه
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات